I'm calling regarding the incident we
reported on the 26th there's been a
report of one of you exposing yourself
presumably there's a conflict here is
here friend
one force two ways of policing put put
the needle on the floor and come out
it's important that we do stuff and
install the show notes not just show
them that we don't won't stand for it
or show the members of the public who
walking around and so witnessing at
least the police are actually doing
something positive and proactive about
drugs but in Staffordshire people who
report crime are having to get used to
not seeing officers turn up every time
the different changes that are coming
about now make no impact on how our
please some of the burden away from you
because some of the things aren't gonna
be sent response that they're necessary
yeah it takes a bit some of the building
away from us but I mean these sorts of
jobs it's and it's a response job every
day the week the Chief Constable here is
faced with rising demand and falling
numbers he's lost a quarter of his
officers through cuts so he's open three
resolution centres where officers can
solve non urgent crimes without ever
meeting the victim we're getting people
quicker we're dealing with them in a way
that suits them as well as it suits us
and we're also engaging with the public
in the debate that says not everything
that he'll call us for requires a police
response
well 999 calls should be unaffected the
101 service is too often clogged up
sorry for the delay in getting through
we're having a bit of a flurry at the
moment it had to change and the chief
here admits that at times they just
can't do the full job we're not
delivering the service in terms of the
investigation of crime getting people
into core and the outcomes the victims
would want because of the stretch and if
if government wants better outcomes for
victims if people want to be confident
that we can do all the investigations to
the extent I would want them to then
resourcing is an issue and until that is
dealt with by government and others to
understand that you can't take a quarter
of the resources now policing in an
environment where it's getting more
complex and more demanding and expect
same outcome police forces up and down
the country of overhauled how they were
austerity has accelerated modernization
it's also fundamentally changed what the
public can expect when they need the
police on their side
Tom Parmenter Sky News Staffordshire